oubliée de mailler le 25 août 1944 124
habitants parmi lesquels 48 enfants
étaient assassinés par les Allemands
encore méconnus ce massacre est pourtant
le plus important perpétré par des nazis
après ouradours sur Glane alors à
l'heure du 79e anniversaire le village
du Sud Touraine a rendu un nouvel
hommage assez victime à travers la voie
des survivants le reportage de Lucas
Chopin
un rendez-vous pour ne jamais oublier
79 ans après le massacre de maillet
encore aucun mot ne semble suffire pour
décrire l'horreur pour décrire les
images gravées comme si c'était hier
dans la tête des quelques survivants
encore en vie c'est des choses que
n'oublie pas
le vrai
comme une huître dans sa coquille pour
essayer
pas t'oublier
mais de me calmer
parce que je lui ai stress cooking
maillet village de mémoire mais une
mémoire retrouvée car il a fallu du
temps pour raconter l'indicible par
douleur par tristesse ou peut-être par
pudeur les bouches sont longtemps resté
cousues on en parlant en famille mais on
en parle pas autrement
car parce que
on avait la chance que dans la famille
je vais ma soeur mais j'avais les
parents j'avais les grands-mères
mais les autres à côté les voisins
c'est un père qui était absent c'est une
merde
une qui se trouvait toute seule
on n'ose pas parler à côté d'eux ça a
été plusieurs années qu'on pouvait pas
en parler mais enfin moi avec les
enfants l'évolution n'en a parlé quand
ils grandissent et tout ça mais c'est
sans doute aussi par envie d'oublier par
envie de passer à autre chose que la
France d'après-guerre a invisibilisé
cette douleur on a recherché comment
dire les fautif
pour ne pas employer un méchant mot pour
employer des fautes
trop tard et on n'a jamais retrouvé de
preuves derrière et pourtant le preuve
elles sont là
si pour ces survivantes témoignées
sommes comme un devoir il n'en demeure
pas moins une peur la peur qu'avec elle
s'éteigne les souvenirs de se passer
sombres il faut se souvenir
mais surtout la chose principale
c'est que ça ne se reproduise jamais
j'ai très peur pour nous
79 ans après le massacre maillet
n'oublie pas et essaye de ne pas faire
oublier au monde ce dont l'humain est
capable